obviously you've been writing for 20
years what's the common thread and all
the stories that you write you talked
about writing about religion and sex
yeah and yes there's definitely a
spiritual element and most of what i
right I'd say spirit spirituality love
and I definitely have with facts we can
turn the camera off and talk about those
later but ya know I really said that
because I work out those issues when you
it goes back to you saying is it easier
to sort of deal with remember being
truthful no right to you and your
writing so I actually deal with all of
that stuff in my writing like religion
and sex and all of the stuff it's
definitely a theme and several of my
screenplays so I get to sort of deal
with it in a real authentic way and and
and not be me without going too deep
into it and we taught you sort of like
the Madonna [ __ ] complex and yeah
perfect and all that okay so and yeah
sort of it's keeping a good girl good
and so so specifically on point because
even in one script called what
reflections white which is part of a
trilogy again trilogy inspired by
Christophe Kozlowski it's all about
spirituality and sex and the art types
in it are literally they don't have
names but the characters are archives
there's a virgin a prostitute a cop and
angel and
and a lover so I like deal with it
really directly in that script do you
almost like what's taboo and then to try
to turn it around and show that it maybe
isn't yes like really show people that
were hiding this stuff but it's really
shouldn't be I definitely explore it
explore issues that are taboo but like
you said shouldn't be taboo they're
taboo it but these are just people
dealing with stuff that we all deal with
and society has at some point said that
these things are taboo but it's not
taboo it's just life it's just life and
things that we all do and you know we we
love we we love we make love we have you
know religion we have issues about
religion we explore all those different
things we go through transformation we
we make mistakes and some of them are
bad and dark and horrible we somehow
hopefully find resolution or absolution
all that stuff so it's not taboo it's
just life you know I consider one of my
scripts to be a faith-based script but
the faith-based world would never
consider it a faith-based script because
ironically it has it has a sexing sex in
it and violence in it and stuff like
that but there's this incredible amount
of spirituality and even religion and
transformation and absolution and
forgiveness and all the stuff that
happens but because we're a little
hypocritical in our ideas about religion
you know because it has sex and violence
in it they would not consider it a
faith-based it's right but it totally is
gotten feedback from people mama i have
what my brother goes ah it's too much
it's too much religion and it he sees it
he's kind of like an atheistic then
other people are like oh it's very
spiritual but even the people who think
of it as spiritual understand that our
idea of faith-based today means it can
have certain elements couldn't possibly
be an r-rated film
right right cuz you know because there's
no sex and violence in the Bible okay
like okay you know we're gonna cut that
I never grow going to church that's why
i don't i don't know but i I'm
fascinated by religion and I'm
fascinated by I will listen a lot of
choice to religious radio shows so I'm
very fascinated by the community that's
built around it and I know that things
that maybe or considered a little taboo
that still exist might be very scary
yeah certain populations I don't know
that's the diplomatic way to put it but
I mean I was brought up as a baptist
christian i consider myself a spiritual
not religious right but most of my
actual characters that I write about our
Catholic interesting so then there's a
lot of guilt yeah like and there but
maybe and having to kind of repenting
and thinking that they're bad and but
then there's a lot of interesting things
to look at and that because I think we
all feel that even if we're not even
doing something that horrible yeah I
think guilt is especially as women were
instilled to feel like we've got a
nurturer and if we don't were bad it's
true yes but you know guilt is just a
terrible thing we should just get rid of
it and so you're right about there's no
room for it no room in a happy place for
go but there is an hour script though
and it makes for more interesting
absolutely
you